welcome back to pj chain design today we
are going to talk about this ring how to
do a cross design on the sides and feel
really nice to the head and also talk
about how to have this cut out design
under the stone are you ready let's get
started
[Music]
we're going to be starting from scratch
i'm starting with the stone and if you
like to have a stone to practice with
you can sign up the newsletter and you
will have a link to download this stone
so coming into the front view let's set
it up for
a circle
type it 0 and i would like to set the
diameter for 16 millimeter
once we finish that let's go ahead to
make the c for the stone
so i'm kind of coming into the top view
and simply just uh using the tube
snapping into the zero
and i would like to have the tube it's
just slightly smaller than the stone
a little bit as long as you don't see it
from the top view you'll be fine and for
the distance roughly about one
millimeter
and click enter and we want something
like this you can have it longer if you
want to because we're gonna trim it off
later anyway and i'm gonna moving this
there now having a tube going straight
down it doesn't look as graceful so i'm
going to control shift holding those two
keys with the gumball and click on this
surface and that's 3d scale down
and maybe just moving up a little bit
so then we will have something like this
taper a little bit all right so if that
look all right to you
uh we are going to do the prong you can
have a one prong or double prong it's up
to you but i do like to have a prong
kind of a follow
this line over here so let's take a look
on the perspective you can see this line
is darker and that's where the seam is
so i would like to duplicate it
the edges of this one so that will be a
line there let me
mark it into the green color so you can
see over there but i need to have this
prong longer it cannot be that short
right so we are going to go to the
straight line snapping into the end
point and make sure that your near is on
and moving your mouse along the line and
hit the tab key
and now you can extend it in exactly the
same angle with that green line so let
me go ahead to join the screen line and
the new line we just create
with this one let's go ahead to pipe it
coming into the top view apparently this
line it wasn't exactly 90 degree of the
stone so i'm actually coming to the
front view and going to use project
to see plan
and hit yes to delete the line
so now it's coming back to the
construction plan we are going to pipe
this guy
on the bottom i actually want them to be
0.8 millimeter something like this and
i'm going to moving this prong down
and let me go ahead to
mirror to the other side so then i will
have a double prong there
all right
make sure that you do not want to
cutting your prong too much more than
uh 20 of the prong thickness apparently
this one is so i'm just going to move it
out something like this
by rotating so it's not cutting too much
there and if you like the result let's
go ahead to bullying union
this guy
all right so i'm going to have a full
prong so let's go ahead to using
the polar array
snapping into the zero
number for four
and we'll have prong like this okay and
again most of the time the orientation
won't be 12 6 3 and 9 so i wanted to
rotate it 45 degree and that will be our
design
double make sure the angle and
everything is right by looking at the
perspective in the render view okay
let's work on the ring shank all right
the bottom of the ring chain is going to
be like this i'm going to
using the arc snapping into the zero and
for something like a less than two
millimeter there or close to two
millimeter
something like this bottom of the ring
chain again i would like to be
thinner so it's more graceful kind of a
taper it down
on the top i would like to have a curve
going here come back to the bottom of
the middle line so i'm going to draw
something like this and if it is
snapping to somewhere it's okay uh
because we are going to
adjust it later on so this is the line i
have as you can see on my perspective
the line is snapping crazy on the first
one so that's coming to the top view
we're going to use project 2c plane
and let's hit yes to delete the input so
now it's flat
now the curve is flat we need to have
this curve is actually follow this
circle there so we are going to use the
curve front two view and we're gonna
click on this one and this one so then
we will have something like this we
actually don't need the bottom one so
let's go ahead to trim the one on the
bottom
and we can hide in this one
okay and let's give it a try and see how
that work
i'm going to
create the rectangle using a rectangle
tool and i wanted something
over
the middle something like this all right
if we want to give it a try let's see
let's go ahead to use a sweep one rail
this is rail this is a cross section and
we'll get something like this notice
that this is kind of over outside and
it's not long enough
so we actually need to get this one in a
lot more and i wanted to be very close
to the prong right so what i like to do
is actually duplicate this edges of one
two
three and four and let's go ahead to
join them and we can delete this one all
right with this one this gives us a
really good guideline for what we wanted
to do
first of all i like this one to be
longer so let me using the scale 1d and
we want this one to be longer something
look like this all right and i also want
it to be narrower
so it's kind of taper ink will look
nicer all right and you can see now it's
still sticky outside so i'm going to
have this one
to get inside of the shape i still have
one corner stick outside and i'm going
to moving in a little bit
all right that looks alright now let's
take a look on the sweet one one more
time
rail cross section cross section and
this time we want to record a history
and let's hit enter
all right click ok there
and double make sure if that is what you
want right we can kind of give it a try
by mirror this guy to the other side
like this and then you will have that
opening and again if you don't like it
you might need to adjust the shape
of this curve if you want this to be
open a little bit more you want to turn
on the control point and edit
unfortunately if you see the control
point this is so many points there so we
need to do some adjustment i do like the
curve on the top but on the bottom i
want them to be open a little bit it's
really up to you so if you wanted to do
that this is my suggestion you want to
rebuild this guy first to be last point
so you can edit it
and then i want to pull
basically this point and this point
pull out a little bit maybe this point
to be out a little bit as well so when
you sweep it will have a bigger opening
there so let's give it a try we wanted
to do the sweep one rail
this is the rail this is the cross
section one and two
and let's click ok now let's go ahead to
mirror
that piece snapping with the zero coming
out like this
then it has a bigger opening there all
right so if that worked for you we want
to take a look on the render view now if
we look at render view this
section right here it doesn't look
really nice all right so what i like to
do
is actually pick up this curve right
there and i want one side taller than
the other side so let's go ahead to
scale 1d
and i want to snap in here on the bottom
somewhere in the middle and just make it
a little bit taller
and unfortunately we didn't record a
history but that's okay we can sweep one
more time
that's using the sweep one more time
this is the rail this is the cross
section
another cross section there remember to
record a history and hit enter
all right and double make sure with your
render view and see if you like the
distance in between if you don't since
we have a recorded history now you can
change it all right
and
now we have this one let's go ahead to
mirror to the other side
and in the sense of the mirror you can
see both this size taller this size is
shorter actually so mirror is not a good
choice so we want to use a rotation copy
equal yes
180 degree
and we'll get something like this so now
it looks more symmetrical okay
now we have this
we need to make the bottom of the ring
shank and to make those solid and you
can bowl in together you just need to
use the cap command
and then it will break the history but
that's okay we're no longer going to
change it all right for the bottom of
the ring shank i simply just going to
use the square
to duplicate it from this point to this
point
again the same thing from this point to
this point
so now i have something like this
oh and it's not fitting to what i have
for the thickness i have
so i simply changing the design which is
not a good practice but
to save the video time i'm going to just
moving this one in a little bit and
moving this one in a little bit
in the real time you have to rebuild the
shank all right
but for the demonstration that's okay
and i'm going to have this one
coming in a little bit something like
this
moving all three up just making my shank
thinner oh by the way uh you want to
have a bottom of the ring shank for at
least 1.5 millimeter because if you get
it too thin like what i have here
usually it will come back for the repair
pretty soon all right so now we are
going to
make sure that the thickness is changing
right so i'm going to have this one to
be split into by the point at the call
here and also the call here
so we have a two open
curve folder rail let's do the sweep two
rail
rail one rail two you got cross section
one and cross section two
so then you will have a bottom of the
ring shank right to make the design on
the gary it's quite simple we can simply
do a design for something like a spiral
let's go ahead to use the command for
the spiral
and i want it to be flat
and so you can do the spiral something
like this
okay so just turn around something like
this all right and i would like to
offset this spiral
and we're gonna do one millimeter
outside and we'll get something like
this
first of all i want to rebuild this guy
to be last point so
let's do eight point
and this guy two for eight point all
right so it's easier to edit and i
wanted to end to be touching so let's go
ahead to moving this point
back to here and of course it's coming
into the point it's not as pretty so we
need to kind of adjust the neighborhood
there
for this to be together we can use the
blank command we're going to blend in
between here and here
moving down the arm with the shift
holding
and let's get something like this all
right and double make sure this is what
you want and let's join those all right
of course this is gonna be too big over
there so i'm going to tilt it a little
bit
and moving things over there
it can cross the middle a little bit and
because it's going to be together we can
go ahead to mirror first
snapping into the zero
holding the shift and we got those two
curves we can trim each other so that's
using the trim command to trim
this curve here this curve here and
don't forget to trim those tiny curve
over here
and hit enter and let's join it right so
maybe a little bit too fat it's cut too
much to the prong
so then we have this guy and we can
simply just using the solid extruded
planar curve straight so extrude the
command to extrude something like this
right
now if you just go ahead to boiling
different this and this you're gonna see
the prong over there right and of course
this is kind of cutting the bottom after
i train the ring it's going to be open
so
what we like to do first is we need to
bowling union this guy first
once we boil in union this guy that we
have
we actually need to make them smaller
and make sure that it stay inside of
ring shank then we want to use the
bowling difference this guy out of this
guy
then we want to draw the cylinder one
more time
snapping to the zero diameter for 16
millimeter and we want to go long
like this and that allows us to trim all
the extra there first that's boiling
difference this one out of this one
and let me make the cylinder one more
time
and we are going to
bowling difference this piece and this
piece by this one
all right so then you will have your
ring just boiling uni and the rest of
the part
i hope you enjoyed the video please let
me know how you like it leave the
comment below thank you for watching and
i'll see you next
[Music]
you